Guten Morgen.
Guten Morgen. Oh, oh, guten Morgen. Guten Morgen. Äh ich wollte doch gerade noch twittern.
Guten Morgen Linas. Ach so, wolltest du das? Mach doch. Twitter doch. Was twitterst du denn?
Ganz geheime Sachen.
Wirst du noch sehen.
Naja, das musst du noch sehen, wohin du kommst. So, wir sind's wieder hier,
Netzpolitik, Ausgabe Nummer dreiunddreißig, die Sommerpause ist vorbei,
Ich hoffe, du wirst dir die Sonne noch ordentlich auf den Bauch scheiden lassen,
Ja, kriege ich nichts für. Also, ich meine, Hetzjagd, ne?
Ja, ja, ja, hätte, hätte der Hund nicht geschissen.
Ciao. Und jetzt?
Jetzt äh jetzt habe ich hier ein bisschen ähm Material.
Zusammengetragen, belastendes Material.
Belastetes Material für unsere Gesellschaft und unsere Zukunft. Ähm,
Es ging, also es war eine, wir überblicken ja jetzt quasi die äh ich habe mal geschaut, wir überblicken quasi jetzt den Zeitraum vom vierzehnten siebten bis achten achten, im Prinzip, ne? Das war, ich glaube, vierzehnter siebter war die letzte Sendung.
Wer wischt mich auf dem linken Fuß? Wann war die letzte Sendung?
Schon äh Nachbuch der Waffen neunzehnter Juli ist die veröffentlicht worden. Mhm.
Neunzehnter? Okay. Mhm. Alles klar, ich dachte, dann äh ja, also vom neunzehnten bis zum,
neunzehnten siebten bis achten achten.
Also es ist man sagt auch drei Wochen. Genau. Ziemlich genau. Mhm.
Aber genau diese drei Wochen eben, ne? Nicht irgendwelche, ja.
Ja, diese, genau.
Da äh ist gedankenswerterweise nicht ganz so viel passiert, aber doch einiges. Zum Beispiel äh wurde dann der der zweite Entwurf,
des Leistungs für das Leistungsschutzrecht vorgestellt von den ähm von den Referenten des äh Bundesinnenministerium Bundesministeriums der Justiz, ja,
und ähm die haben den jetzt, haben das jetzt umformuliert, das ist eigentlich sehr, sehr interessant. Also ähm fragt man sich wirklich, ob was was sie sich denken? Äh also sie ist recht fast sich ungefähr so zusammen.
Tun als was was sie sich herausnehmen, dass sie jetzt ihre Gesetze selbst,
umschreiben und sich nicht von der Lobby vorschreiben lassen.
Ja, aber da sieht man auch, was dabei rauskommt, ne. So, jetzt haben sie, nee, es, aber das ist aber echt supergeil. Also,
Ich verstehe ja nicht so viel von Jura, ne, aber wenn diese also es geht los mit der Presseverleger, hat das ausschließliche Recht, das Presseerzeugnis.
Müssen vielleicht nochmal kurz zusammenfassen, was bisher der Stand war. Bisher war der Stand, dass äh äh gesagt wurde, so jetzt haben wir das nicht nur im Koalitionsvertrag drinne, sondern jetzt wollen wir das auch machen
und im Wesentlichen stand da drin, mit jeder, der auch nur irgendwie einen Buchstaben äh aus irgendeinem Zeitungsartikel äh zitiert, hat irgendwas zu zahlen.
Erst nicht da ständig drin hat irgendwas zu zahlen, sondern,
Verleger hat das ausschließlich ausschließliche Recht. Und das heißt natürlich, dass der Verleger dann.
Lizenzen rausgeben darf, kann, muss äh et cetera ohne Erlaub.
Zensen, Anzeigen, Abmahnungen oder was auch immer, dass der auf jeden Fall eine möglich.
Genau und auch nicht der Urheber, sondern der Verleger. Der Verleger.
Genau, das war ja schon der erste schöne Teil, ja, der der Verleger hat das ausschließliche Recht, also der das heißt, damit ist schon mal irgendwie so implizit zementiert, dass der der Urheber, der da seinen Artikel schreibt
vollständig abzugeben hat an den an den Presseverleger, ne, weil der Presseverleger hat das ausschließliche Recht
Presseerzeugnisse oder Teile hiervon zu gewerblichen Zwecken öffentlich zugänglich zu machen.
Von Urheber kein kein.
Nein, nein, geht ja um Pressefrei ist er ist Leistungsschutzrecht für Presseverleger. Und.
Na ja. Und.
Äh das ist aber übertragbar und erlischt nach einem Jahr immerhin, ne? Ich meine, im Urheberrecht reden wir ja sonst von fünfzig bis siebzig Jahren,
nach dem Tod, insofern hier sind wir noch ganz günstig weggekommen.
Erlischt es auch erst ein Jahr nach dem Tod von Axel Springer.
Aber,
Und da erinnern wir uns im ersten Entwurf hieß es, ähm zulässig,
die öffentliche Zugänglichmachung von Presseerzeugnissen für nicht gewerbliche Zwecke.
Das war also der Paragra,
dann oder der der Absatz, der dann den den Bloggern und so den den Hintern aus der Schlinge ziehen sollte.
Mhm.
Und den haben die jetzt allen Ernstes im zweiten Entwurf geändert, diesen Absatz, in zulässig ist die öffentliche Zugänglichmachung von Presseerzeugen, Zeugnissen, soweit sie nicht durch die Anbieter von Suchmaschinen erfolgt.
Das heißt, sie haben's jetzt also wirklich quasi konkretisiert, dass sie da ein Gesetz haben, was sich, was ausschließlich deren einziger Anwendungszweck gegen Suchmaschinen ist.
Das, was sie immer meinten, was ja, wo gingen sie ja eigentlich gar nicht vorgehen wollten ursprünglich, das war doch das Statement, oder? Dass es gar nichts mit Google zu tun hätte.
Ja, dass also der sie haben dann gesagt, also in der Begründung steht dann ungefähr so drin, dass der,
ähm dass so eine Suchmaschine einen Mehrwert quasi,
generiert oder deren hauptsächlich sich aus dem anderen speist. Ja, also wenn es die Presseartikel nicht gäbe, könnte die Suchmaschine ihr Geschäftsmodell nicht verfolgen und äh entsprechend müssen die deswegen an die.
Verleger was abdrücken, ja? Es gab da ja schon nach wie vor, also es gab ja, glaube ich, schon von Mario Sixtus vor einem Dreivierteljahr diesen Vergleich, das wäre, als würde jetzt der Restaurantbesitzer vom Taxifahrer Geld verlangen, dass der da äh,
Kunden hinfährt und ähm der Sebastian Dosch äh stellte dann auch sehr schön einfach die Frage letztendlich brauchen die Verlage Google?
Und braucht Google die Verlage. Ja, also das,
ja schon relativ offensichtlich, wer da jetzt irgendwie. Aber ich find's ganz scharf,
Es hat ja noch andere Probleme, wenn ich jetzt sage, ein Anbieter von Suchmaschinen,
dann muss ich erstmal eine Definition von Suchmaschine hinkriegen.
Ja. Weil jedes Block hat ja auch eine Suchfunktion.
Also genau, das wird schon mal sehr schwierig irgendwie glaube ich juristisch,
Idee einer Suchmaschine zu definieren, kann sein, dass das schon jemand versucht oder gemacht hat oder dass es deine Definition gibt, aber,
so wie ich die äh die juristische Sprache einschätze, glaube ich, das wird, ist eine,
Ist eine schwierigere Angelegenheit, eine Suchmaschine ähm wirklich zu erklären. Und was mich nach wie vor eben,
wundert ist, dass es ja hauptsächlich irgendwie um Google News sich drehen soll und zu Google News muss man sich anmelden.
Also man muss, wenn man, also ich weiß, es kann sein, dass das bei ähm,
vielleicht für ganz große Presseverlage äh Google News, dass äh sich dann hinsetzt und,
selber versucht, das irgendwie zu ähm,
äh äh zu paßen, was die da veröffentlichen,
als ich Netzpolitik org, bei äh bei äh
Bei Google News angemeldet habe, musste ich eine spezifisch generierte Seitmap zur Verfügung stellen und mich quasi bei denen, also diesen Feed dann sagen und ich äh melden und sagen, hier Freunde wollt ihr uns nicht aufnehmen? Und dann kam irgendwann nach drei Wochen, ja,
Nehmen wir auf in in das in Google News, das heißt also es ist halt kein craller oder so, ne, also äh,
Also ich glaube, das wird nochmal, das wird nochmal echt süß, wenn sie äh was was sie da mit ihrem.
Wie absurd. Also ich meine, das ist das ist das ist so absurd. Ich meine, wer kommt denn da überhaupt noch,
mental überhaupt noch,
mit, mit so einem niedrigen Niveau der Gesetzesschreibung. Ich meine, es geht ja nun wirklich völlig in die falsche Richtung und es ist ja auch so absehbar. Ich meine, ich habe parallel so,
Noch äh äh gab's, glaube ich, auf Twitter mindestens auch in Box, glaube ich, so ein bisschen die äh äh Debatte, wo gegen das jetzt alles äh äh mal wieder so grundsätzlich äh verstößt. So erstmal die Frage mit ja, hier Schutz der Urheber und so weiter, ja, das äh steht ja vorne an. Die Urheber werden hier überhaupt
nicht äh äh genannt, auch nur in irgendeiner Form und das auch noch vor dem Hintergrund der
Realität, dass heutzutage den Urhebern von den Verlegern ohnehin schon quasi alles abgekauft wird, was irgendwie geht, also den Journalisten,
der halt schreibt, ja, also da da geht schon sowieso alles weg und dann soll darüber hinaus,
noch dieses ohnehin schon fragwürdige Recht auch noch explizit,
geschützt werden sollen und dann sollen auch noch diejenigen, ich meine, ist ja auch noch nicht mal so, dass Google Geld,
damit verdient, ihnen.
Diese Kunden zuzuspielen, also das Taxifahrervergleich hinkt,
insofern, als das der Taxifahrer ja zumindest noch Geld bekommen von dem Kunden,
Ja, aber es ist ja äh so, dass Google News keine Werbung schaltet
und die äh Formulierung, dass sie damit ja Geld verdienen, ja nur so eine rein theoretische Konstruktion ist, mit, dass sie vielleicht unter Umständen dadurch, dass Leute das benutzen, auch andere Sachen von Google benutzen, wo dann Geld verdient wird
Also da komme ich einfach überhaupt nicht mehr mit und ich weiß gar nicht, wem sie das überhaupt noch vermitteln wollen.
Ich muss noch ganz kurz zu dem, was du gerade sagtest, sagen, der Paragraph vorgeschlagene Paragraph siebenundachtzig H,
sagt ähm der Urheber ist an einer Vergütung angemessen zu beteiligen.
Aber ich meine, was heißt angemessen zu beteiligen? Also kannst du dir schon wieder was ist dann, ich meine, das ist so ein Paragraph, da
kann keine Sau irgendwie auf Basis dessen kann ja keine Sau sich irgendwie mal juristisch durchsetzen, weil da steht ja schon wieder angemessen drin. Was ist eine angemessen?
Also ähm ja ja und ähm.
Ein Prozent wahrscheinlich oder sowas. Nach Abzug.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, weißt du, aber äh was der der andere Punkt, den du sagst, äh ich meine, wie kommen jetzt überhaupt die Presseverlage auf die Idee, dass die so einen Leistungsschutzrecht haben wollen? Ich denke, ähm.
So ganz klar ist mir das auch nicht so wirklich, aber man muss ja irgendwie gerade bei so irrationalen
Ängsten dann wirklich mal auch auf den Grund gehen, um vielleicht zu sehen,
was ist, was ist es, was sie umtreibt? Was äh was ist es, was diese Menschen
in so eine starke Furcht treibt, dass sie irgendwie das Land,
in so eine äh groteske reißen, ja, dass es da ein also der.
Vor allem ich stelle mir mal vor, dieses Schutzrecht würde jetzt in dieser Form, was ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen kann, aber angenommen, es würde jetzt so beschlossen werden, was wäre das Erste, was passiert?
Google News macht einfach dicht.
Genau, Google News macht einfach dicht, wie es sich in Belgien auch schon gemacht haben und dann kommt einfach,
mehr auf ihre Webseiten, weil wahrscheinlich der Traffic, der über Google News erzeugt wird,
sie zahlen nicht, ich habe hohe zweistellige Prozentzahlen äh äh gelesen. So, aber dann ist da einfach äh äh Crickets und äh auf diesen Webseiten.
Äh ich also das auf jeden.
Ja, die Leute werden alle zu den Blogs geschickt.
Na, ich denke, also was also was Google News auf jeden Fall macht, warum ich das irgendwie in meiner Liste der Seiten habe, ist halt, weil ich habe beispielsweise meine,
drei, vier Nachrichten, Medien, Webseiten irgendwie in dem,
regelmäßig ansurfe und dann gucke ich halt äh was auf Google News irgendwie steht. Und auf Google News werde ich hauptsächlich dann zu den Seiten gespielt, wo ich.
Nicht so hinkommen würde. Genau.
Ohnehin sowieso anlese. So und das heißt, wenn jetzt Springer sich durchsetzt,
damit das das sie letztendlich zum Gesetz äh verhelfen oder für ein Gesetz arbeiten, dass Google News einfach dicht macht,
heißt das, dass keine Springerseite von mir jemals wieder besucht wird,
ähm andererseits aber sicherlich bei ähm dass viele Leute, die sage ich mal die Welt oder so als Startseite haben, dann auch nur dort bleiben,
und nicht mehr auf den ähm nicht mehr über Google News den Umweg zu vernünftigen Medien finden.
Na wieso? Ich meine, die Blogs bleiben ja noch drin.
Ach so, äh du meinst Google News.
Die lesen dann alle Netzpolitik org.
Ja, können Sie gerne machen, sowieso hoffentlich.
Na ja, ich meine, das ist ja de facto dann die Konsequenz, weil sie werden ja nicht Google News einstellen,
Sie werden bloß alle rausnehmen, wo nicht klar ist, dass sie da darauf linken können. Das heißt, alle Presseverlage. Und übrig bleibt äh keine Ahnung, der Freitag, Kater, Netzpolitik Org,
Meter Ebene im E. So, fertig. Das war's. Das ist dann die das Echo.
Wie sie hier presse.
Die Zeitung können sie dann ihren Pressespiegel der Woche irgendwie zusammenschreiben, indem sie einen Blogs zusammenfassen.
Ja, aber ich glaube, wir brauchen da jetzt gar nicht weiter, also ein Satz, wo wo also ein Gesetz, in dem der außer es soweit sie nicht durch die Anbieter von Suchmaschinen erfolgt. Deshalb einfach,
vollständig äh also ich meine, das kannst du ja niemals so lassen,
Also was äh der Anbieter von Suchmaschinen, der muss ja erstmal Suchmaschine definieren und Anbieter und was heißt und dann sagen sie Anbieter von Suchmaschine,
nicht etwa im Rahmen des Findens durch eine Suchmaschine,
Das heißt, wenn nicht jetzt irgendwie Anbieter und Google einen Anbieter der Suchmaschine und Google News trenne.
Ja. Ja.
Ja, dann steht dieses Gesetz da und sagt, ja, äh so weiter habe ich jetzt nicht gedacht. Also es ist ja, also die die ist halt, selbst mir als als Nichtjurist fällt auf, dass diese, dass diese Definition so gar nicht gehen kann.
Na ja, viel Spaß damit noch.
Ja, das wird äh lustig, irgendwie äh sorgt für Spaß. Lass uns weitergehen.
Trojaner. Thomas Petry, der bayrische,
Beauftragte für Datenschutz und Informationsfreiheit hat sein ähm seine,
oder sein sein Artikel, ich glaube seine Untersuchungsbericht fünfundsiebzig Seiten oder so,
zum äh den Prüfbericht zu,
veröffentlicht. Da ging es also, wir erinnern uns ja, vierundsiebzig Seiten sind's an die Entdeckung des von,
programmierten äh Trojaners, der äh im Rahmen von Strafermittlungsverfahren,
Ähm auf den Rechnern von bestimmten Personen gefunden wurde und sich dann als Myware von eher durchschnittlich bis weit unterdurchschnittlicher Qualität ähm erwies,
Gab's da eine Analyse von Cars Computerclub? Und dabei die Erkenntnis, dass äh bestimmten gesetzlichen Voraussetzungen, die für die Quellen Telekommunikations Überwachung.
Gesetz von bestimmten Regeln dafür nicht entspricht, denn,
grenzt ja den Anwendungszweck der Infektion eines Rechners auf,
Abhören von laufender Kommunikation und nicht etwa,
drauf, dass der Rechner tatsächlich durchsucht wird,
und so wie es aussieht ist das wohl auch äh eigentlich durch diesen Schutz der Integrität von Computersystemen,
dass ein äh Staatstrojaner so etwas machen würde. Also es gibt im Prinzip soll es,
Laut deutscher Gesetzeslage keinen Staatstrojaner geben, sondern eine Quellen-TKÜ, also ein Programm, was es ermöglicht, die äh Kommunikation an der Quelle zu überwachen, bevor sie in die Verschlüsselung übergeht.
Das war so die Idee davon. Und jetzt hat äh der Thomas Petry da seinen Bericht veröffentlicht. Erstmal sehr schön, das Programm wurde dreiundzwanzig Mal auf richterliche Anordnungen hin in Bayern eingesetzt,
unter anderem zum Beispiel gegen irgend so ein Bodybuilder, der anabolika vercheckt hat. Ja, also irgendwie Drogenhandel, jetzt nicht irgendwie großartig Terrorismus oder so. Ja, so einen, so einen, so einen kleinen Dealer mit Anabolika da, der wo die dann nachher alle Akne kriegen und und dicke,
Ähm dann äh kritisierte er, dass die Ausschreibung dieser Software schon irgendwie sehr ähm,
Mangelhaft war, weil sie, weil in der Ausschreibung nicht drinstand, dass die Software auf,
überschüssige Überwachungsfunktion verzichten soll. Also sie haben gesagt, die Software muss äh Skype abhören können, die Software muss Chats abhören können, die Software muss das und das können. Habe aber nicht geschrieben, dass die Software nicht mehr darf.
Wodurch dann natürlich Tür und Tor geöffnet war für Standard oder Standardstart,
Staatstrojaner oder eben,
Mauer und dann keiner, also es hat keinen Einblick in den stattgefunden, weder von Seiten der äh ausschreibenden Behörden noch jetzt von Seiten des Datenschutzbeauftragten,
Das große Problem war ja, dass diese dass diese Staatstrojaner in Deutschland erweiterbar war, das heißt, man konnte Code nachladen und ausführen,
ähm was also letztendlich die Möglichkeit ist, den kompletten Rechner zu manipulier
oder zu infiltrieren oder mit dem einfach zu machen, was man möchte
aber natürlich hat er keine Hinweise gefunden, dass das auch getan worden wäre. Ich hatte ja schon mal erklärt, dass diese,
Nachladefunktion ähm.
Weil viele verschiedene Gründe hat,
warum man die in einer Myware eigentlich haben möchte, ja? Nämlich weil man möchte,
sie natürlich updaten können. Ja, vor allem gegen vielleicht, wenn so etwas passiert wie jetzt dem,
dem digitales Trojaner und auch dem Finn Fischer Trojaner und dem Trojaner von Hacking Team passiert ist, dass er gefunden wird, dann möchtest du hier deine infizierten Systeme updaten auf eine neue Version, die hoffentlich nicht mehr entdeckt werden kann, ja?
Oder Betriebssystem, Upgrades und so weiter.
Oder neue Aufgaben halt nachladen, die so bisher noch nicht äh drin waren.
Genau, das möchte man natürlich auch. Also ich ich,
aus Angreiferperspektive, aber es hat natürlich diese Implikation, dass äh,
sich dadurch einen einen Zugriff auf den Rechner habe, dort Dinge zu verändern,
macht die ganze Sache natürlich per se vor Gericht ähm schwierig.
Äh
So, aber er sagt das, äh es gäbe keine Hinweise, dass das getan worden wäre. Ja, vielen Dank. Also das haben sie ihm wahrscheinlich auch nicht irgendwie einen Brief geschrieben, da in sein kurisches Büro in Bayern, wo er da seinen Bericht schreibt
Ähm dann hatte der Trojaner ja eine Screenshot-Funktion, die sich auf den gesamten Bildschirm bezog und das äh ist natürlich ein,
juristischer Graubereich, weil das natürlich sehr weit,
über die Kommunikation hinausgehen kann, ja? Wenn ich jetzt selbst wenn ich jetzt so ein Chatfenster aufhabe und das bedeckt so die Hälfte meines Bildschirms,
daneben habe ich jetzt wieder theoretischer Fall, meine äh Diagnose, meine eingeskettete HIV-Diagnose vom,
oder oder sonst was, ne?
Äh ist damit quasi mit diesem einen Screenshot ein ein enormer Eingriff in meine Privatsphäre getätigt worden,
äh vor dem mich das äh Grundgesetz schützt eigentlich
Deswegen ist also diese Screenshot-Funktion natürlich eine sehr große sehr große Problematik. Allerdings hat das Landgericht Landshut sie irgendwann mal in irgendeinem Fall äh für zulässig erklärt, diese diese Screenshots.
Und in neun Fällen wurden äh Softwarelisten ausgelesen, das heißt, es wurde also äh geschaut, so was was sind hier für Programme installiert, was nutzt er für Software? Und ähm,
Dann ging's natürlich irgendwie los. Die ähm die Gegner des Staatstrianners äh sagten dann,
Jubel im Prinzip so okay, es wurde alle an, alle Vorwürfe, die der Chaos, Computerclub in seiner Analyse erhoben hat, durch den Daten durch den Datenschutz bestätigt,
Ich rede ja vom Datenschutz, genauso wie Verfassungsschutz und so. Der Datenschutz hat das bestätigt. Und ähm.
Gleichzeitig sagten aber dann äh hier der, wie heißt der, Joachim Herrmann? Heißt er doch, ne? Der Bayerische Innenminister,
Ähm der will ihn natürlich äh bald wieder einsetzen und sagt, ja, weil in dem Bericht ja steht, dass davon niemals ähm.
Nichts Böses passiert ist.
Niemals was Böses passiert ist oder du hast jetzt gerade.
Konnte es äh ihr konntet uns ja nichts nachweisen.
Ihr konntet uns, wir haben das, klar, der hatte diese Funktion,
aber ähm wir haben die ja nicht benutzt, das sagt er ja selber, das ist kein Beweis dafür gibt, dass wir die genutzt hätten, ja?
Ja, schwierige.
Ihr habt's ja nicht rausbekommen, dann können wir ja weitermachen.
Genau und der will also jetzt unbedingt äh schnell ein äh neuen ähm Staatstrojaner haben.
Anders macht.
Da hat er jetzt sogar nicht großartig irgendwie hat äh der Hermann sich da jetzt nicht großartig zu geäußert. Ähm,
sagte also nur, ähm wir wir müssen jetzt schnell dieses dieses,
Instrument der Strafverfolgung kennt man ja, wie das dann so heißt,
diese unverzichtbare Dokument,
und ähm ich gucke mal ganz kurz, ob ich hier ein.
Dass das Leben eines Staates nicht mehr vorstellbar ist.
Ach so, na ja, er sagt zumindest auch immerhin, er will die Hinweise des Landesbeauftragten nach äh äh sorgfältig prüfen und sie bei einer Datenschutz gerechten Fortentwicklung der Software einbeziehen. Ne, immerhin,
Äh aber er sieht sich klar von den Vorwürfen entlastet,
der CCC äh erhoben hätte,
und ja, muss jetzt halt möglichst bald wieder ähm mir jetzt möglichst bald wieder äh,
Quellenticker über beziehungsweise Staatstrojaner haben.
Damit wären wir beim, wären wir so beim fließenden Übergang zum nächsten Thema.
Ja, aber was haben wir denn dazu jetzt noch äh groß sagen, ne, oder?
Ja, also ist nämlich sehr interessant, weil was nämlich ähm,
Was mit im im Bereich Staatstriern, da gibt's nicht noch was Neues. Also was was ich sehr, sehr spannend fand. Und zwar wurde der äh wurde die Software Finn Spy,
gefunden und ist ein Teil der des Fin Fisher IT Intusion Kids.
Gefunden.
Weil Aktivisten in Bar rein. Also vielleicht kurz,
kurz äh äh ich hatte schon vor einigen Folgen mal darauf hingewiesen, dass es eine Firma gibt, die sich Gamma International nennt,
mit äh Firmen,
Sitz irgendwie vermutlich wohl in England oder Firmenanmeldungen in England. Da sind aber auch,
hauptsächlich deutsche wohl in dieser Firma aktiv.
Die machen quasi die Rollen diesen Staatstrojaner Markt professionell auf. Das heißt, die haben,
ernstzunehmendes komplettes Kit, nicht nur eine Myware, sondern die bieten auch verschiedene Infektionsmaßnahmen an, unter anderem so eine SSL-Menne-Box, die du einfach nur beim
Provider hinstellst und die dann irgendwie Betriebssystem-Updates mit dieser mit diesem infiziert
Das heißt, sie können nicht dann ähm können dich dann quasi infizieren, ohne dass irgendjemand
Attachment schickt oder oder sonst was, sondern möglichst dann also was weiß ich, so ein so ein Softwareupdate, ne, also gibt's ja,
von Software, die irgendwie ohne vernünftige Signaturprüfung äh sich runterlädt,
schaut man einfach, wenn äh Tim,
Jetzt irgendwie das Update macht, dann kriegt er eben den,
mit dazu, ne? So, solche Dinge, zum Beispiel,
bieten sie auch an, kann man sich alles sehr, alles sehr schön dokumentiert auf der Seite Back Planet. Dann haben sie dieses äh Fin Firewire, das ist also so ein Zugriff auf ähm.
Die Passwort geschützt sind, weil der Fireport direkten Zugriff auf den Ram ermöglicht,
und damit kannst du dann diese Passwortsperre, solange der Rechner zumindest noch an ist, kannst du damit diese Passwortsperre auflösen,
so Windows Rechner, ne, dieser Bildschirm ist gesperrt, steckst in Kabel dran und dann äh,
ist die ist die Passwortsperre weg und dann infizierst du den Rechner direkt noch über den Fireport,
der ist eine Sache vor ein paar Sekunden. Das ist so diese typische Anwendungsfall
zeigen Sie mal Ihr Laptop, den müssen wir mal eben durch den anderen Scanner schieben, sondern,
und äh das bauen die also alles, das bauen die alles, dann haben sie ihren noch für Mobiltelefone und so. Die sind also, die sind richtig im Business und dieser ist also,
letztendlich dann der der Trojaner, den sie bei den, bei dem äh Opfer,
auf der, auf dem Rechner dann installieren. Und das ist so 'n Trojaner sagen wir mal auf dem Niveau wie man sich das eigentlich vorstellen würde für 'n Staatstrojaner. Also vernünftige Arbeit so. Und die haben jetzt da waren also meldeten sich ein paar Leute.
Vernünftige Arbeit aus der Perspektive eines.
Entwickler.
Security äh Menschen.
Genau. Also das ist so, da da findet man nichts,
so lächerliche Fehler wie in der in dieser äh Digita Skywear. Ähm,
Und was er sie hat, was also jetzt passierte, war äh dass in Bahrain so ein paar ähm Aktivisten oder äh so ähm E-Mails bekamen,
Und da waren ähm,
Dateien drin, die äh die hatten so einen Anhang. Es war ganz lustig, mit einem white to left over right. Das heißt, die der Dateiname war irgendwie so formatiert, dass er von rechts nach links ausgeschrieben wird und dass du quasi den Dateinamen rückwärts siehst,
da stand dann quasi, also als Dateiname irgendwie Echse sowieso Punkt JPG. Aber in Wirklichkeit war es JPG Punkt sowieso Punkt Echse,
Wenn du draufgeklickt hast, hat sich dann diese installiert und irgendwann ein am am Ende dieses Prozesses dafür gesorgt, dass dir auch ein Bild angezeigt.
Das war so der der Infektionspflicht, den die da in Bareien gewählt haben. Und das hatte offensichtlich ähm,
Also sie hatten offensichtlich nicht daran, äh nicht noch in diese mähende Mittelattacke investiert oder in, sondern die haben halt tatsächlich an diese Aktivisten E-Mails geschrieben
und dann hat das diese, da gab's eine sehr schöne Analyse, weil die Leute, denen kamen diese E-Mail dann eben komisch vor und dann haben sie sie erstmal an geschickt
News hat die dann an Citizon Lab der Universität Toronto geschickt, wo es Leute gibt, die sich damit auskennen
angeschaut dieses,
Und das äh infiziert erstmal so äh Windows Systemprozesse,
hat irgendwie Schutzfunktion, wenn die Bagger irgendwie laufen, dann schmieren die die ab,
Also, ich meine, das sind ja alles immer Fehler, die du finden musstest. Das verteidigt sich laut eigenen Angaben,
vierzig Virenscanner. Das heißt,
Möglichkeiten auf die ganzen Virenscanner ähm.
Und ähm hm ja genau äh erkennt die auch andere, die sie nicht abschmiert abschmieren lassen können, erkennt er und die tatsch dann so den Fred, dass der irgendwie woanders läuft und so. Also das das ist wirklich auf hohem Niveau,
Und ähm als Arbeit äh verrichtet das dann so unter anderem, dass es irgendwie sammelt so alles irgendwie in einem versteckten Verzeichnis. Sammelt Konfigurations- und Passwortdateien, macht Screenshots, hört Kommunikation
E-Mails, Chats, ab äh hat noch einen Key-Locker am laufen, also bezeichnet sowieso schon mal alle Tastaturaufeingaben ein, auf
Das heißt also auch Passwörter und so weiter, wenn man sich irgendwo noch anmeldet. Verschlüsselt die Sachen dann,
die Schlüsselgenerierung war irgendwie nicht so,
hing irgendwie stark von der Systemzeit ab, sodass es denen gelungen ist, das wieder zu entschlüsseln.
Und dann hat diese Version des Trojaners das alles an eine,
IP geschickt, die irgendwie am Telekom Anbieter in Bareien gehörte,
Und ähm diesen Server, der wurde auf so ein paar verschiedenen Ports kontaktiert und das Schöne war, wenn man den auf Port achtzig kontaktiert hat, also HTTP, zeigt mir mal eine Webseite. Dann hat er geantwortet, mit hallo Steffi.
Hallo Steffi. Hallo Steffi. Ready?
Hallo Steffi. Ja, also es kam einfach nur zurück so, hallo Steffi.
Und dann dann haben wir jetzt noch.
Auweia. Dann haben wir jetzt noch so richtig Deutsch, ja.
Ja, wie gesagt, also es ist unklar. Also, der Typ von.
Richtig, dass Deutsche, hallo, du hast jetzt nicht ein.
HALLO STE FFI Ausrufzehren so und laut,
Planet. Also dieser Sammlung, der Wiki League Spyfiles,
ist einer, der äh einer der Eigner von Gamma International, der Martin J, ich glaube auch Joachim Münch,
Und das ist einer, der ist in der,
so in der Exploite Szene sowieso nicht besonders unbekannt, weil der zum Beispiel auch an der Entwicklung der Back Trek
äh
beteiligt ist. Also steht auf jeden Fall. Es ist bei Wikipedia eingetragen als einer, der auf den geht das so ein bisschen zurück,
Und der hat laut Planet Info äh fünfzehn Prozent an Gamma International,
Und tritt wohl auch auf Konferenzen dann ähm auf. Also so einer, der,
eine der entscheidenden Personen bei Gamma. Wenn man den Informationen bei Backblende Punkt Info,
so vertrauen kann. Fünfundachtzig Prozent gehören aber irgendwie einem.
Loven Nelson, ja,
aber in Großbritan Großbritannien wohnt. OK also die haben.
Haben also diese Mager und jetzt wurden die gefunden. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, dann haben sich natürlich alle irgendwie weltweiten,
Analytica da drauf geschmissen, haben das haben das Ding irgendwie analysiert und inzwischen gibt's natürlich dann so ähm,
Snordregeln, wie man das im Netzwerk erkennen kann, also Snord ist und Netzwerküberwachungs äh Programm, wo man dann,
wie diese Verbindungen rausfiltern könnte, um zu erkennen, dass bestimmte ähm Rechner im Netzwerk vielleicht damit,
infiziert sind. Die ganze Sache ist natürlich nur also man kann davon ausgehen, bei einer,
auf dem Niveau, ja? Also ich meine, jeder, jede Virenscanner-Umgehung ist da irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, wie viele hundert Stunden Arbeit, ja.
Ähm
dass die sich, wenn sie ein Ding auf auf dem Niveau schaffen, dass sie selbstverständlich auch noch irgendwie,
zwanzig dreißig andere Wege einfach in der Tasche haben
die sie nicht die pläuen, bis sie nicht müssen, ja? Also nämlich,
also dass man davon ausgehen kann, dass auf diesen Fall, dass irgendwann diesen entdeckt wird, schon seit Jahren vorbereitet sind.
Ähm,
Ansonsten hat dann in einer weiteren Analyse das fand ich dann noch sehr spannend. Jemand danach gesucht, oh wo habe ich denn jetzt diesen Link? Der hat dann geschaut, wo ist noch Server gibt, die,
also den ähnlichen Fingerprint haben. Das heißt, die die gleichen Ports aufhaben,
und auch mit hallo Steffi antworten.
Hat er gefunden in Indonesien, Australien, Katar, Äthiopien, Tschechien,
Estland, USA, Mongolei, tschechischer Republik, Litauen,
und die in Dubai der Vereinigten,
Arabischen Emirate. Also das wäre jetzt mal,
so offensichtlich, das scheinen so die jeweiligen Proxis zu sein,
die dann äh weiterleiten zu den Commanden Control Servern von Gamma im Zweifelsfall.
Und die Vermutung liegt natürlich dann nahe, wenn in diesen Ländern solche Server stehen, äh dass die entsprechend dann auch in diesen Ländern.
Eingesetzt werden
sowieso aber sieht es so aus, dass da also jede Infektion eher hochgradig ist, das heißt jeder kriegt sowieso einen anderen, eine andere Version von der,
mal per se, weil die es eben professionell machen. Also wirklich professionell,
und äh insofern ist also,
eigentlich nicht davon auszugehen, dass dieser Fund von Finn Fischer jetzt großartig,
dafür sorgen wird, dass das ähm,
Geschäftsmodell von Gamada in irgendeiner Form beeinträchtigt wird.
Das Ziel von diesem waren jetzt Bindungsrechner.
In diesem Fall Windows-Rechner, ja, aber das gibt's auch äh laut Firmenangabe für MACS.
Mhm. Ist das schon mal gefunden worden irgendwo.
Also was gefunden wurde, das ist leider so ein bisschen untergegangen. Es gibt nämlich noch eine zweite Firma, die sowas macht,
Es sind italienische Firma, die sich Hacking Team nennt,
deren äh deren Trojaner wurde irgendwie ein paar Tage später äh auch entdeckt und analysiert. Ist aber so ein bisschen untergegangen, weil alle sich auf diesen Ball geworfen haben. Der,
ohne Frage der größere Fisch ist. Also Gamma sind halt
Wie ich schon sagte, die Leute, die die sowas ernsthaft und professionell machen und,
Zumindest, was, was ich, also so wie ich das jetzt lese und was ich für Schlüsse daraus ziehe, persönlich, ohne da jetzt also ich gehe nicht davon aus, ähm,
ein herber Schlag versetzt wurde. Kann sein, dass ich mich täusche? Kann sein, dass das alles war, was diese Firma drauf hat und die jetzt nackt dastehen
aber da jetzt ihre Server sich inzwischen schon wieder anders verhalten wie zu den Zeitpunkten als diese Analysen stattfanden,
und nicht irgendwo massenhaft Leute sich melden und sagen, hier mein Virenscanner,
Meldet mir,
von ja mindestens auszugehen ist, müssen Jahrhunderte davon irgendwie äh infiziert sein,
dass ich da mir nicht ein einziger Fall bekannt ist, wo jemand nachm Virenscanner-Update oder so dann das Ding bei sich gefunden hätte,
gehe ich also davon aus, dass sie am Tag, an dem das veröffentlicht wurde, innerhalb von zwei Stunden alle Kisten auf irgendeine andere Version geupdatet haben,
dass da jetzt munter weitergeht.
Wäre jetzt so meine meine Vermutung, ja.
Ja, es ist eine äh böse und schmutzige Welt da draußen,
Kann man nicht anders sagen. Auf jeden Fall ist irgendwie Security,
zunehmend wichtigeres äh Thema. Bin auch mal gespannt, wie sich da äh,
Apple jetzt so macht, weil ich glaube so dieser seit ewigen Zeiten,
vorausgesagte, ja, wenn ihr erstmal verbreitet seid und so weiter, ja, dann
wird es auch euch schlecht ergehen, das also die wiederkehrendem Jahr seit zehn Jahren,
und bisher ist ja noch nicht so viel passiert.
Bin gespannt, ob äh ob es jetzt der Fall ist, so richtig mit Rum bekleckert, haben sie sich ja in den letzten äh äh Tagen und Wochen nicht gerade, was so ihre äh äh Sicherheitsmethodiken betrifft, wird spannend.
Also wenn man,
den Werbe äh Aussagen von Gamma und äh Hacking Team trauen kann, sind im Moment was die Staatstrojaner angeht, die Windows-User sogar noch auf der besseren Seite, weil für macOS Versionen ähm,
wurden da jetzt nicht gefunden. Wobei ich glaube, dass dieser Hacking-Team Trojaner sogar, das kann sein, dass da auch die macOS-Version gefunden wurde. Der konnte ja hier auf mehreren Betriebssystemen laufen, also was, ich habe die Analyse nicht so genau gelesen, wie die von ähm,
Wie die von dem äh Finn Fischer. Ah vielleicht nochmal abschließend zu der Idee des Staatstrojaners, also warum warum das so problematisch ist? Ich meine, man könnte ja sagen,
Man könnte ja vielleicht auf Anhieb durchaus sagen, wenn man mit Hilfe eines Staatstrojaners ähm,
Zum Beispiel so was wie diesen NSU, den nationalsozialistischen Untergrund ähm hätte,
schneller aufspüren oder vielleicht sogar an Taten hindern können, dann äh würde man ja vielleicht,
schnell auf die Idee kommen, dass das ein äh probates Mittel ist.
Gegen solche äh Gruppen vorzugehen. Es ist halt nur leider nicht durch das Grundgesetz gedeckt. So äh zu ermitteln, ja? Also wie gesagt, es ist das das,
In einem Artikel einen sehr schönen Vergleich, dass nämlich,
Bei der normalen Untersuchung eines Rechners. Ja, also normalerweise kommt irgendwann die Polizei rein,
schleppte einen Rechner raus. Und dann wird er von,
Computerforensickern oder Leuten, die irgendwie so eine Fortbildung gemacht haben,
unter Laborbedingungen untersucht, hat keine Netzwerkverbindungen mehr, äh die Festplatte wird erstmal sowieso komplett gespiegelt und das System wird eigentlich gar nicht mehr ausgeführt, sondern so
und was sie mit dem Trojaner machen, ist ja ein laufendes System überwachen, was aber gleichzeitig zum Beispiel auch von jemand anderem noch infiziert sein könnte.
Es müsste ja noch nicht mal der Staat selber bösartige Beweise auf deinem Rechner platzieren, weil sondern es könnte ja auch sein, dass jemand anderes auch eine da drin hat und dieses System manipuliert.
Und ähm also quasi ist das Beweismittel wird am laufenden Band, ändert sich im laufenden Band und wird von der ist durch die Software selber verändert. Und das ist also etwas, was viele dann, denke ich, mit Recht sehr kritisch sehen,
und ähm das Zweite, was was, glaube ich, sehr wichtig zu sagen, ist,
Vergleich zu dieser Laboruntersuchung des Rechners. Ähm
agieren diese Trojaner ja sehr autonom, ja, die machen irgendwie in bestimmten Abständen die Screenshots
oder dieser ähm dieser Finn Spy, ich meine, der schert sich eh nicht um Recht und Gesetz,
versammelt halt erstmal sowieso auf der Festplatte rum, verschlüsselt alles und schickt das rüber. Und das heißt, der ähm,
berücksichtigt dabei ja gar nicht,
Also diese Software kann ja gar nicht, das sind ja nur Dateien, die sie behandelt, die kann ja gar nicht berücksichtigen, was äh jetzt eventuell in dem Ordner privat,
dass man da nicht reinschauen dürfte oder so, ne. Also sehr,
ist 'ne sehr spannende Sache, aber man sollte sich da glaub ich nicht großartig was vormachen, dass.
Thema der Staatstrianer erledigt wäre, ne? Und ich habe ja schon mal die Hypothese geäußert, ähm dass ich sowieso davon ausgehe, dass das nächste, was in Deutschland zum Einsatz kommt, von Gamma kommt.
Mit der Prothese im Moment noch alleine da stehe, aber.
Wenn man's ja sehen.
Ja, also gefährlich. Müsst ihr aufpassen.
Jo. Und jetzt?
Verlängerung der Schutzfristen im Urheberrecht. Man würde ja meinen, weißt du,
würde ja meinen, man würde ja meinen, dass äh irgendwie weißt du, wenn wenn irgendwie,
die Hölle los ist im urheberrecht und und die GEMA und alle rennen so rum und,
irgendwie selbst im öffentlich rechtlichen sind Talkshows dazu. Man will ja meinen, dass dann irgendwie mal,
Der der geschickte politische Stratege sich sagt, ach weißt du was?
Wir halten einfach mal den Mund, ne? Nee, aber jetzt stellt sich heraus, EU-Richtlinie vom siebenundzwanzigsten Dezember zwanzig elf, muss bis zum ersten November zwanzig dreizehn umgesetzt werden,
Und diese EU-Richtlinie, die ist also schon offensichtlich vor fast einem Jahr äh,
herausgegeben worden. Die sieht also eine harmonisierung der Schutzdauer für,
Musikkomposition mit Text und eine Verlängerung der Schutzdauer von Rechten ausübender Künstler und Tonträgerhersteller von fünfzig auf siebzig Jahre vor.
Da gibt's irgendwo einen Bereich, wo nicht die siebzig Jahre äh gelten?
Erstaunlich, also das das ist jetzt auch, es kommt übrigens dieser dieser Gesetzesentwurf auf,
Also der geht zurück auf diese erwähnte EU-Richtlinie und das ist auch ein Referentenentwurf des Bundesministeriums der Justiz. Und zwar ist das der achte, der zum Leistungsschutzrecht war der siebte. Also die sind so, kommen sie quasi in Folge so, ne. Die sagen also, sie wollen,
Die Schutzdauer einer Musikkomposition mit Text,
soll also siebzig Jahre nach dem Tod des längst Lebenden der folgenden Personen existieren, Verfasser des Textes,
Komponist der Musikkomposition, sofern beide Beiträge eigens für die betreffende Musikkombination mit Text geschaffen wurden.
Dies gilt unabhängig davon, ob diese Person als Miturheber ausgewiesen sind. Also offensichtlich wollen sich hier so ein bisschen den Fall angehen, dass jemand etwas singt zu einem,
eine Melodie, die es schon gab oder so, dann geht's wohl irgendwie anders, ja. Also sie haben offensichtlich Schwierigkeiten, überhaupt mal so zu gucken, wer tot sein muss.
Ja, ich wundere mich, warum sie das nicht gleich noch ein bisschen weitergefasst haben irgendwie. Man könnte ja auch noch den Babysitter äh mit einbeziehen, der währenddessen auf die Kinder aufgepasst hat und so. Das äh.
Aufgepasst. Ja. Hm. Es geht.
Jahr hat ja auch maßgebliche, sonst wäre das ja alles gar nicht zustande gekommen.
Ja
Äh stimmt, das ist eigentlich alles so ein bisschen das geht das nur nicht weitgehend genug. Ist ein guter Anfang einfach nur, ne?
Aber andererseits hat der Künstler ein äh Recht gegenüber dem Tonträgerhersteller, dass der das auch anbietet,
Und wenn der Tonträgerhersteller das nicht anbietet, dann kann der Künstler dem Tonträgerhersteller kündigen,
Allerdings erst fünfzig Jahre nach der ersten erlaubten Nutzung äh oder Aufführung und nach ein Jahr ein Jahresfrist.
Nochmal zusätzlich. Also erst einundfünfzig Jahre.
Also genau, wenn die, wenn ich nach fünfzig Jahren feststelle, der verkauft die CD nicht mehr, dann kann ich das anmahnen, dass jetzt die Idee wieder verkaufen muss und wenn er's dann nicht macht, dann ist eine Jahresfrist um und dann kann ich,
Den Vertrag, den ich mit meinem Tonträgerhersteller habe, kündigen. Also auch hier natürlich ein sehr groß,
sehen, der Schutz der Urheber, ja, der ist diesen Gesetzen aber sowas von ihn herrennt, ne?
Fünfzig Jahre, ich meine, da könnte ja fast sogar so auch sein, dass das irgendjemand erlebt.
Könnte sein, dass wir da noch tatsächlich einen Fall von haben, ja? Und ähm,
Aber ähm wenn der Künstler da ist dann auch wieder so ein so ein Schutz des des Urhebers, so wenn der die Rechte an den Tonträgerhersteller überträgt,
Da muss er zusätzlich zu dem zu dem zu dem, was er für die Übertragung der Rechte bekommt, zwanzig Prozent der Einnahmen bekommen und kann nicht darauf verzichten. Da ist also tatsächlich so eine Art,
Urheberschutz mit drin, ne? Du gibst da quasi deine Rechte ab und dann musst du danach,
Prozent der Einnahmen dauerhaft bekommen. Da gibt's keine Diskussion.
Und äh die Verwertungsrechte erlichen siebzig Jahre.
Das soll jetzt generell im Urheberrecht generell gelten. Grundsätzlich.
Das scheint jetzt ah ja, ich habe mir wieder nur die Sand. Also ich habe das jetzt so verstanden, dass es nach wie vor um Musik.
Ja genau.
Hm, ich gucke mal gerade ganz kurz,
gehen wir mal davon aus, dass es nur, ja, äh, mit Uhr hier bei Filmwerke, Musikkomposition mit Text. Ja, Musikfilm,
Und äh ja.
Das ist alles so ein Dreck.
Ja, also es ist echt äh spannend und ähm Verwertungsjahr Rechte, die Verwertungsrechte edition siebzig Jahre nach dem ersten Erscheinen,
Und oder fünfzig Jahre nach der Erstaufführung, falls es keinen Tonträger gibt,
Also ich weiß ja nicht, also aber immerhin.
Halbes, Jahrhundert, mein.
Immerhin die Verwertungsrechte siebzig Jahre nach Erscheinen, ja? Das heißt also da,
theoretisch sogar noch leben, ja? Das heißt nicht siebzig Jahre nach deinem Tod. Also da gibt's nochmal was,
Also ja, ich meine, da kann man auch jetzt nicht mehr viel zu sagen. Das äh ist sehr,
amüsant und.
Tja, unser Justizministerium, da wird Skifreiheit gekämpft.
Zwanzig Prozent.
Das ist alles so ein Quatsch.
Ja, also ich meine, ist davon also ich weiß gar nicht diese Debatte mit diesen fünfzig bis siebzig Jahre? Hat das irgendeine.
Also hat das irgendeine ernstzunehmende Folge? Außer, was diese Mickey-Maus-Sachen angeht,
Und was die Unmöglichkeit angeht, in naher Zukunft oder überhaupt in in innerhalb eines Menschenlebens geschaffene Kultur irgendwie allgemein zugänglich zu machen,
Also gibt es gibt es wirklich einen finanziellen Vorteil, den irgendjemand noch siebzig Jahre.
Nach der Veröffentlichung eines Werkes hat. Also ich denke mal, es geht dann um Beatles Platten wahrscheinlich. Die müssten jetzt irgendwie.
Alles Walt Disney.
Ja Walt Disney, aber jetzt mal so erwartet, es erwartet doch ein,
Also ich meine Walt Disney und die Beatles, ja. Das waren noch Phänomene komplett,
neuer, also die sind so groß geworden, weil es, weil es irgendwie gerade erst das Bewegtbild gab,
Deswegen wurde Walt Disney groß. Heute ist doch nicht mehr ein Disneyfilm ist doch bei weitem nicht mehr,
so ein so enormes, viel beachtetes Werk, wie es das damals war. Ähnlich wie Beatles Alben,
Also was die Beatles an.
Ein Film ist kein vielbeachtetes Ereignis.
Im Vergleich zu nein, kein Vieh beachtetes, historisches Ereignis, dass man, dass man auf so lange Zeit schützen müsste.
Ob da so ein historisches oder nicht, spielt ja an der Stelle auch überhaupt gar keine Rolle. Die Frage ist halt einfach nur, wie lange darf
Äh wie lange ist es angemessen, dass irgendjemand äh eine Exklusivität eingeräumt wird auf sein Werk so?
Derzeit ist die Definition äh ohnehin schon ein bisschen verfahren, weil es halt
über den Tod hinausgeht, was ich an sich schon mal etwas fragwürdig äh äh finde, auch wenn man das,
wohl argumentieren kann, ja, aber warum es dann sozusagen nochmal ein komplettes Menschenleben danach
maximales äh Fast äh äh auch noch dauern soll. Dafür habe ich einfach keinerlei,
äh ja also da sehe ich jetzt einfach keinerlei Anlass für.
Und mein, mein, mein Argument wäre jetzt, also genau dieser, wenn wir dann von irgendwie einem Zeitraum von irgendwie, sagen wir mal, hundert Jahren reden, dass doch in hundert Jahren für den größeren Teil der Filme äh sich keine Sau mehr interessieren wird.
Jetzt interessiert sich schon für den größten Teil der Filme keine Sau.
Eben da, also das das war mein Argument, jetzt interessiert's sich schon für den größten Teil, keine Sau. Und genauso bei Musik, ja.
Ja gut, aber es gibt natürlich Filme, die sind halt ewig. So. Es gibt halt so Sachen, die sind uralt,
aber die sind halt äh immer noch topaktuell, so und die werden's auch in dreißig Jahren noch sein,
in dreißig Jahren das das Dschungelbuch gucken und äh
weil es einfach ein geiler Song ist so und dann kann Disney halt auch immer noch die Hand aufhalten, weil ja da ist ja die Putzfrau äh ist ja äh erst äh fünfundachtzig gestorben und deswegen,
hält es halt auch noch ewig. Ja. Es geht einfach darum, die Pfründe ja ist doch egal, ob es Disney oder sonst irgendwas ist.
Das ist jetzt wieder Disney. Nehmen wir,
interessiert sich irgendeine Sau nächstes Jahr noch für den Batman-Film?
Das wissen wir da nicht.
Aber wenn, okay, wenn.
Nächstes Jahr bestimmt auf jeden Fall, na klar natürlich. Da gibt's viele Leute.
Blu-ray rauskommt, dann kann man den kriegt man den besser.
Höhe, den haben den viele auch nicht gesehen. Ich meine, wie viele Leute gucken so einen Film im Kino,
mögen zwar im Vergleich,
Zahlen sein, aber absolut gesehen äh mit den X Milliarden Leuten auf diesem Planeten, das ist halt Quatsch.
Also wenn dir nicht wieder ein Server abraucht, dann wird hier Logbuch Netzpolitik in siebzig Jahren auch noch zu hören sein,
Fünfhundert Jahren und dann würde ich sagen, Freunde, äh wenn der Tag, an dem der dieser Be,
wie heißt der Batman Night Returns oder so? Batman oder wie heißt jetzt dieser aktuelle Batman-Film?
Return auf der Night oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe ihn noch nicht gesehen.
Darknight Rises, Darknight Rises, so wenn wenn der Tag, an dem Batman Dark Night Risis gemeinfrei wird.
In, sagen wir mal, irgendwas um die hundert Jahre,
dieser Tag irgendeine Signifikanz hat.
Wenn's mal in hundert Jahren ist.
Ja, vielleicht hundertvierzig oder werden wir ja sehen.
Ich meine, da sind bestimmt irgendwelche Zwanzigjährige, die da jetzt irgendeine Urheberschaft dran haben.
Ja, werden wir sehen. Also wir das können.
Leben dann nochmal hundert Jahre, also nochmal achtzig Jahre.
Das ist nämlich genau das, was passieren wird.
Plus siebzig sind hundertfünfzig Jahre.
An dem Tag, an dem an dem Batman gemeinfrei wird
wird es niemand merken können, weil die weil die Rechtslage so unklar ist, dass man überhaupt nicht festhält. Es sind ja diese ganzen verwaisten Werke. Das ist ja jetzt schon das riesige Problem, dass keiner den den Quatsch überhaupt über so lange Zeit äh da äh nachhält, ja,
und aber sollte der Tag irgendeine äh Signifikanz erlangen, dann äh hätte ich mich getäuscht,
Ja, also Schutzdauer, aber ich meine, fünfzig Jahre, siebzig Jahre kommen, ist eh nach unserem Tod versäumt, also man kann da nur mit dem Kopf schütteln,
Dann gibt's ja noch jemanden, der sich auch mit diesen ganzen Urheberrechten nicht so ähm ernsthaft auseinandergesetzt hat. Wir hatten das Thema ja schon mal äh kurz erwähnt, da ging's um den äh Kim Schmitz.
Der sogenannte Herr Dot com, wie er sich selber nennt und wie,
hat der sich offiziell umbenannt. Ich meine, er hat der jetzt wirklich einen Pass, wo dot com drin steht, warum schreibt der Spiegel die ganze Zeit dot com?
Ballett. Weil es so ist. Interessant.
Kimbel ist das.
Ist der Arsch Kimbel, ja der,
der schon irgendwie in der Mailbox Szene die Leute hat Hops gehen lassen auf seinen Kisten,
ne? Ähm,
und der ja auch verurteilt. Ich ich kann jetzt man kann jetzt wieder freiwillig sprechen. Ich komme da gleich zu. Der ja verurteilt ist wegen Insiderhandels und so weiter, ne? Der hat ja irgendwie
Was war das irgend so eine Internetplattform oder so?
Hatte der erst irgendwie sackweise die Aktien gekauft.
Na ja, er würde es retten und so.
Dann hingestellt und gesagt, ich pumpe hier paar Milliarden in das Unternehmen, dann sind die Aktien hochgegangen und er hat die wieder verkauft.
Ja, der hat halt äh also der wurde dann wegen Insiderhandels ähm natürlich äh auch verurteilt.
So ein Großmahl. Osama mit dem Laden wollte auch fangen.
Der Typ geht so gar nicht.
Dann wollte, dann wollte er äh genau, dann hat er die äh äh,
oder sowas, ne? Punkt org irgendwie so eine Seite gegründet und hat gesagt, wir sind jetzt Hacker und wir fangen Osama bin Laden. Dann wird die Seite gehackt.
Dann hat er das irgendwie alles wieder sauber gemacht und hat gesagt, ja, das war das,
Schreiben eines Hackers und den haben wir jetzt natürlich aufgenommen. Fünf Minuten später seid ihr wieder gehackt. Nö.
Und einmal mit Profis zusammenarbeiten, ey.
Ja dann hat er auf jeden Fall, wir wissen ja inzwischen alle, äh dann hat der ähm,
Megaupload gegründet und hat dann da äh eine ein eine,
Möglichkeit gegeben einfach Dateien hoch und herunterzuladen und der Vorwurf hauptsächlich Leute lautet ja darauf, dass er Leute motiviert hat, mit Bonusprogrammen dort Dateien herunterzuladen, die,
sehr ähm die sehr äh hochzuladen, die sehr gerne heruntergeladen werden.
Und ähm man kann sich ja ungefähr denken, was für Dateien das dann wohl so waren. Ähm,
Und dann ist ja oft Initiative des FBI dann irgendwie so äh neuseeländische ähm.
Neuseeländische Aditerrorkommando bei ihm reingerannt und er lag irgendwie mit der Schrotflinte im Bett oder so, der in seinem Schutz,
raum, der hatte irgendwie in seinem auf seinem Millionenanwesen dann irgendwie so ein, so ein,
Raum, in dem er sich dann verschanzt hatte,
ich hab das Video erst heute Morgen gesehen, das wurde erst vor kurzem veröffentlicht, das Video von dem von dem,
der Hausdurchsuchung, dass er bei ihm stattfand, ne? Echt ganz gut, wie die da so mit dem Hubschrauber irgendwie echt so Tiefflug.
Ach echt, das Video gibt's? Hast du das verlinkt irgendwie.
Gleich mal raus. Ähm die fliegen also mitm mitm Hubschrauber wirklich, also der ist ein guter Hubschrauberpilot, brettern so da rein, dann stürmen die in das Haus rein, rammen die Tür ein und hier,
Das fand ich ganz schön. Also sei nur angemerkt, weil er ja jetzt die ganze Zeit immer Fotos von seiner Frau und seinem Kind twittert, ja und Instagram und so,
erzählte dann,
Vor Gericht erstmal nur von sich und so viel
Also kann auch sein, dass er alleine zu Hause war, ja? Also mag sein, oder dass die Frau einfach nicht mit ihm in einem Bett steht, was auch sehr gut sein kann.
Dann ist halt irgendwie erzählt halt nur wie er sich in
in Sicherheit gebracht hat in diesem Raum. Also keine Ahnung, Familie kommt auf jeden Fall in dem Fall nicht vor. Wie gesagt, kann sein, dass sie gar nicht da waren. Ähm,
und ähm dann haben sie ihn dann irgendwie rausgezehrt und dann haben sie ihn, wie's bei einer Verhaftung natürlich üblich ist, also ich meine
wenn die irgendwie mit ihren schwarzen Masken und Sturmgewehr und
zweiter Handfeuerwaffe mit vier Magazinen im äh bei dir reinkommen. Da musst du halt auch mal davon ausgehen, dass da ein,
ne? Also die haben ihm dann halt ein paar auf den Boden gelegt und
Knie in Rücken und so. Äh und einer hat ihm auch auf die Hand getreten. So so lautet seine Aussage.
In reinsten, saubersten Denglisch vorgetragen.
Ja, Rettung und dann habe ich auch irgendwie anscheinend gedacht.
Auweia.
Okay, aber jetzt äh genau, lange äh lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Man könnte, glaube ich, sagen, dass,
Also wie ist das zu beurteilen? Dieser Raid, der da bei ihm stattgefunden hat, er sagte ja dann noch so, dass also,
Helikoptergeräusche in seinem Vorgarten äh werden für ihn nichts ungewöhnliches, weil er häufig Gäste empfängt und die.
Das geht gar nicht. Ich meine, an der Stelle muss man ihm vielleicht wirklich mal Tribut zeigen, ja. Also,
was der für Eier hat, ja?
Über Jahrzehnte immer wieder den Dicken zu machen, ja, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und auch egal, ich meine, so viel, so viel,
So viel ähm Niederlagen, wie er schon hat, einstecken müssen, ja. Ich glaube, das hätte jetzt auch nicht jeder geschafft. Der scheint irgendwie in seinem Hirn,
Da fehlen einfach so äh ein paar chemische äh Botenstoffe,
in irgendeiner Form dafür sorgen, dass man sich deprimiert fühlt,
Ja und äh die sorgen wahrscheinlich auch gleichzeitig dazu, dass man irgendwie sich selbst äh fortwährend für den größten hält und dann natürlich auch,
ähm so inszeniert, dass eben immer so äh maximal, ne, jetzt,
ist ja noch dieses alberne Musikvideo von ihm rausgekommen, ja, Mister President, wo er sich dann jetzt auch noch wirklich so zur,
Speerspitze der Anti-Acta,
Revolution und und Meinungsfreiheit in in USA.
Mega.
Also,
das ist so dieses einzige Stück Respekt, das, das, das, das man einfach so ignorant sein kann, dass dass man dann auch immer noch,
hat, sich immer noch wirklich zum Weltchef zu zelebrieren, obwohl irgendwie,
klar ist, dass einfach schon lange nicht mehr geht, ne.
Also der fühlt sich ersatzt sich jetzt wie gesagt dieses besagte Musikvideo. Kim dot com äh the Truce, welcome out. Mister President äh äh und es, also die bitte einmal wenigstens den Anfang ein.
Ich hab's geahnt.
Bitte einmal den Anfang nur, also der Anfang ist einfach so scharf. Also da weißt du schon Bescheid. Bevor wir dann gleich mal zum ernsten Teil kommen, weil da gibt's ja auch noch einen ernsten Teil.
Einen ernsten Teil gibt's auch noch.
Ja, es gibt einen sehr ernsten Teil.
Oh Gott, jetzt wird's ernst, meinst.
Vorher möchte ich seine seine äh wie er sich als Martin Luther King da äh darstellt äh nochmal besprechen.
Urheberrechtsverletzung.
Nee, nee, das ist. Das hat er extra gesagt, ja. Download, the Song in join the movement.
Oh weia.
Movement, ja, also das ist wirklich einfach unfassbar.
Wie kann der sich mit, wie kann der sich mit Martin Luther King vergleichen.
Habe ich doch gerade eben erklärt. Da fehlt chemisch was. Genetisch, keine Ahnung, irgendwas. Vielleicht ist mir auch irgendwann mal was entfernt worden von Aliens. Das andere Erklärung habe ich dafür nicht.
So und jetzt aber hier unser, unser Freiheitskämpfer, ja, dieses Video immerhin auch achthunderttausend Leute haben sich das schon angeguckt und finde das irgendwie,
enorm knorke. Ähm,
oder auch nicht, ja? Aber also du kannst einfach nur dir an den Kopf fassen. Aber okay, hat er jetzt gemacht,
und ähm jetzt hat sich endlich etwas, was wovon ich ja schon seit langer Zeit wusste, aber worüber ich nicht so sprechen konnte, jetzt sind endlich die ganzen Abmahnungen,
an Torsten Kleins durch,
Und sind alle abgeschmettert worden. Thorsten Kleins ist ein äh freier Journalist, äh der sich sehr viel mit ähm netzpolitischen Themen auseinandersetzt. Äh unter anderem für äh den Heise Verlag schreibt,
und äh für die TAZ. Und der hatte zweitausendeins schon angefangen mit dem Kimble Report. Und da hat er quasi so diesen ganzen,
Unsinn, der so in den Medien über über,
äh sich da so angehäuft hatte, hat er dann,
da genauestens drüber berichtet. Jetzt muss man dazu sagen, dass Thorsten Kleins.
Glaube ich, der ein der Mensch ist, äh den ich oder der Mensch unter den Menschen, die ich kenne, ist der am
absolut akribisch und genauesten ist. Ja, also der der schreibt mir eine Mail, wenn ich in irgendeinem Artikel so den Hauch einer Implikation habe, dass etwas eventuell theoretisch falsch verstanden werden könnte,
dann sagt Thorsten Kleinst, Linus, falsch. Sondern hat er aber auch, also er hat halt recht. Also ist halt sehr genau, ja?
Ist ein Megapedant.
Ich wollte jetzt nicht Pedant sagen, aber essen pedant. So und.
Ah, ich glaube, das würde ihm sogar gefallen.
So, aber er ist auch er ist unser.
Wo du zuhörst. Weiter so!
So und der hat eben wohl zweitausendeins angefangen mit diesem Kimble-Report und,
alles so zusammen äh gesammelt und ähm,
bekam dann irgendwie so immer mehr Links dieser Dokumentation, führten dann so ins Leere, hm sind einige pleite gegangen und so. Und Kimbel hat ja oder Kim Schmitz hat's ja irgendwie immer geschafft, doch noch so in den Medien immer so als,
krasse Figur dazustehen, ne? Er hatte schon seit, ich weiß nicht, seit wie vielen Jahren der Hausverbot beim Kongress,
Computerclub hat. Ähm wie gesagt, keiner will eigentlich was mit ihm zu tun haben. So ein.
Ich bin eben auch einmal begegnet in meinem Leben.
Auf unserem Messestand stand mit irgend so einem fetten Sportwagen
So, also wieder auch mit irgend so einem absurden Projekt ist einfach immer dasselbe, ja,
Und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass das eine Menge Leute dem seinem Charme da auch irgendwie,
ne? Weil der hat halt einfach keinerlei Hemmungen, ja? Der rollt dann auf dich äh äh zu irgendwie so mit seinem,
seiner mächtigen Erscheinung, der ist ja auch auch noch groß, also er ist ja nicht nur.
Der ist genauso breit.
Ja, äh der ist auch noch groß und kommt dann irgendwie an und ich meine, wer jetzt keine Ahnung hat, äh äh kann mir gut vorstellen, dass der einfach Herr Schaden von Leuten um sich herum hat, die ihn schlicht einfach für den größten halten.
Fliegt dann irgendwie, also Wasser, wo so üblicherweise Max da fliegt dann irgendwie mit so einem Helikopter
drauf.
Auch der Meister, er ist auch der Meister der Täuschung an der Stelle. Ich meine äh damals war ja so Sachen hip so,
ja, ich habe jetzt hier demonstriert, wie man am frankfurter Flughafen da irgendwie die Sicherheits äh,
Systeme überwinden kann. Und ich bin da jetzt irgendwie reingekommen, ja? Und dann dick gefilmt und pipapo. Da war irgendwie nix Großes dabei. Eigentlich sind sie ja nur durch ein Tor gefahren, das war's, ne? Aber es ist ja, aber die diese diese Inszenierung des Nichts
die liegt ihm einfach wie keinem zweiten. Ja, also so wirklich, also aus aus,
nichts, äh was über Großes zu äh inszenieren,
Die Nummer hat da irgendwie drauf. Ja, aber ist nicht angenehm. Für sie ist, sich zu sehr loben. Okay, Thorsten.
Thorsten Kleins sammelte also Informationen so über äh,
Kimble und das, was irgendwie die Medien über ihn berichten und da kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass äh Thorsten da sehr viele
Dinge gefunden hat. Und gab jetzt endlich bekannt und sagte so, wie einige bemerkt haben, dieser Kimble-Report ist
offline, ja? Hat er vor zehn Jahren mit angefangen und was war der Grund dafür? Er hatte für,
Artikel, die er für den Heiße Verlag und für die TAZ geschrieben hatte,
Ähm drei äh von drei verschiedenen Landgerichten, einstweilige Verfügungen bekommen,
Was Aussagen anging, die er in diesen Artikeln getätigt hatte. Unter anderem äh jetzt muss ich selber mal kurz schauen, was er jetzt sagte, so die Pleite von Data Projekt durfte er nicht äh erwähnen.
Tagt. Ja. Protect. Nicht Projekt.
Habe ich Projekt gesagt? Oh, Protect. Ähm äh durfte er nicht erwähnen
er durfte irgendwie als dürfte er eigentlich gar nichts sagen, ja? Und die,
die Strategie wohl dahinter ihn an verschiedenen Gerichten mit einstweiligen Verfügungen zu über äh sehen. Äh überschritten war wohl
da für ihn die Prozesskosten in die Höhe zu treiben. Also es war ein sehr gezieltes gezielter Angriff auf den Verlag,
Die Verlage und diesen Journalisten,
ihn einfach mit hohen Prozessrisiken zu konfrontieren und irgendwie äh mundtot machen, mundtot zu machen, ja? Ähm
Glücklicherweise haben dann heiße äh und die TAZ zu Thorsten gehalten und haben das mit ihm durchgefochten und jede einstweilige Verfügung,
erst außer Kraft gesetzt und dann gerichtlich abgewiesen,
natürlich monatelang gedauert und in diesem,
ähm in diesem Rahmen hat äh Thorsten dann auch diesen Kimbel Report sofort offline nehmen müssen,
da natürlich, wenn der zehn Jahre alt ist, äh,
hunderte Dinge drin sind, wo er sich die nächste einstweilige Verfügung mit fischen kann.
Sagt selber, dass er glaubt, dass es auch ein Zusammenhang damit gibt,
dass sie den Kim,
dann irgendwie im Januar oder wann äh verhaftet haben äh weil dadurch hat er jetzt natürlich andere Dinge zu tun als äh Thorsten Kleins irgendwie zu gängeln, ja. Also unser Freund hier, der Internetfreiheit,
drei einstweilige Verfügung auf einen Journalisten geschüttet, der mit ganz hoher Sicherheit,
kein einziges Mal irgendwo etwas eine Aussage tätig, den die ja nicht hundertprozentig denken kann. Also wenn,
Person das äh nicht macht, dann äh Thorsten.
Was ist nun Mister Präsident, ja?
Ja, was ist Mister hier, Mister Kimble, was ist mit Mister dot com, ja? Äh es wird sehr interessant, was du da gemacht hast, ja? Na ja, also so viel, so viel zu unserem äh.
Lest euch mal, lest euch mal wirklich den Wikipedia Artikel durch über äh Kim Schmitz, ist wirklich,
unfassbar, was man so in so einem kurzen Leben äh so alles.
Wie viele Leute man es schafft übern Tisch zu ziehen, ne?
Ja, also wer wen er alles beschissen hat und, und, und fortwehrend uns einfach immer wieder Leute gibt, die auf ihn reinfallen, ist wirklich unglaublich, ja?
Alles dabei von Graphenreuth bis,
Telekom unfassbar.
Aber vielleicht noch einen kleinen äh einen kleinen Hinweis, also diesen Artikel von Thorsten kann ich auch nur sehr empfehlen, der,
auch bei uns verlinkt und unter diesem Artikel findet sich dann äh ein Kommentar,
Äh und dieser Kommentar kommt von jemandem, der sich dein Freund nennt,
und sagt, du hattest deinen Spaß?
Wer zuletzt lacht, lacht am besten, du wirst dich noch wundern, Clans, versprochen.
Thorsten, schreibt da drunter, dieser Kommentar kam übrigens von einer LP aus Neuseeland.
Ja ja.
Ja, unser Kimmel, ja.
Ja, aber er ist angreifbar, das merkt man.
Aber so, jetzt kämpfen wir erstmal schön. Jetzt setzen wir uns alle eine Basken mit so eine Sonnenbrille auf und kämpfen erst mal mit Kim Schmidt. Nachdem er jetzt schon gegen und so, so so wild gekämpft hat,
machen wir ihn jetzt mal zu unserer Internetfreiheit,
das schon mal der erste Schritt, ja. Genau. Wie Martin Luther King.
Thorsten vor Präsident.
Der Martin Luther King hat ja auch die ganze Zeit Journalisten verklagt und bedroht.
Und Kreditkarten verkauf.
Du machst.
Insiderhandel, den Aktivismus, ja? Das war alles für die, für die Bewegung, ja?
Und wenn da so ein großes Haus hast, wo die ganze Zeit deine Freunde mitm Hubschrauber, ist ja alles, das sieht ja alles der Freiheit, ja.
Okay, solange wir hier noch nicht abgemahnt worden sind, äh lass uns mal,
Thema nicht mehr ertragen irgendwie. Wir sind ja.
Drauf anlegen.
Maul, Schluss, aber hier über meine achtziger Jahressongs sich wieder beklagen und dann kommst du mir mit sowas. Schlimm,
Okay, letztes Thema.
Letztes Thema. Ähm Zeit Online hat jetzt eine Leaking-Plattform.
Ja, ist doch schön.
Ja, ist sehr schön, vor allem, weil es ja lange Zeit keine gab und man also ähm,
sagen muss, dass es den Anschein macht, nach einigen Verbesserungen,
Plattform zumindest sagen wir mal ein Mindeststandard an Sicherheit bietet,
Ähm es gab da anfangs irgendwie ein bisschen äh einige.
Begriff Plattform jetzt die richtige Bezeichnung ist, dass,
Ja äh ich hab's mir jetzt nicht so genau angeschaut, wie du wahrscheinlich, aber soweit ich,
genau, es ist, ja, es ist, genau, aber es ist, sagen wir mal, ein ein Kommunikationsmittel,
mit Zeit online geschaffen, wo man über das Internet weitgehend anonym,
mit äh den Redaktionen dort kommunizieren kann, ohne eben,
wie das Wort anonym schon impliziert, ohne da seine äh Identität preisgeben zu müssen. Das heißt, man kann da irgendwie Dokumente reinwerfen, inwieweit die äh anonymisiert werden automatisch, das weiß ich nicht. Also ich meine, inwieweit das,
gelingt es sozusagen nochmal eine andere Frage, aber das äh da muss ich, glaube ich, auch jemand, der liegt, auch vor allem selber erstmal darüber Gedanken machen oder sollte er zumindest,
oder sie und äh darüber hinaus ist dann aber auch noch eine hin und her Kommunikation für Nachfragen et cetera, ob irgendwelche ausgehandelten äh Schlüssel dann,
möglich. So und dass das getan wird, das finde ich überhaupt schon mal cool, weil das zeigt einfach, dass man da eben sich so ein bisschen ähm,
Zukunft annähert. Man überrascht mich jetzt auch nicht bei Zeit on, das ist bei Zeit Online geschieht, weil,
Ja, da es zumindest einige Leute gibt, die eben bisschen über den Tellerrand hinausdenken.
Ja, es gibt, also es gibt, da muss man noch da vielleicht dazu sagen, es gibt ähm also, wie du schon sagtest, diese
Dokumenten, Einsendungen, Dokumenten, Bereinigung, von, sage ich mal, gängigen Metadaten,
äh ist natürlich in gewisser Form ähm sage ich mal, zum Scheitern verurteilt, weil es gut sein kann, dass natürlich eventuell
jedem ein gesondertes Dokument gegeben wird, sodass die, dass das Dokument natürlich trotzdem noch den Whistleblower,
irgendwie,
äh ähm,
identifizieren kann oder so, aber es es wird, als wären auf jeden Fall Maßnahmen ergriffen, um die
offensichtlichen Fehler irgendwie zum Gehen und das geschieht auch im Rahmen dieser Metadatenentfernung. Das heißt, die die werden also sofort,
Fallen weg und da,
Die Dateien bleiben auch nicht auf dem Server liegen, sondern gehen sofort an die Redaktion und so also bestimmte grundsätzliche Sicherheitsmaßnahmen so eines,
Online-Briefkastens wurden da berücksichtigt, andere,
man sich vielleicht darüber hinaus noch wünschen würde, nicht. Deswegen verlinke ich jetzt auch auf den Artikel, in dem das System erklärt wird. Das finde ich nämlich ganz besonders wichtig, dass man,
Also wer meint da etwas bei denen abgeben zu müssen, weiß, was welchen Schutz ihm das bietet und welchen nicht.
Und was ist das ähm der South Cold ist ja veröffentlicht.
Genau, ja noch ganz kurz, also äh wollte noch sagen, da drunter haben sie, das finde ich auch eine sehr schöne Sache, also man könnte das wirklich jetzt vielleicht als die Zukunft,
dessen sehen, was irgendwie journalistische Leaking Whisselblewing, Plattform oder Möglichkeiten bei Presse im digitalen Rahmen angeht. Sie haben da drunter die Liste der Redakteure, die das dann bekommen. Und zwar bekommen sie es alle.
Stan Wolfgang Blau dabei, der geschätzte Kai Biermann,
stellvertretende Chefredakteure und,
drei Leute vom Investigativ Resort, ja? Die kriegen dann, die kriegen diese Dinge.
Mhm. Das heißt, man weiß auch genau, welche Personen es sind. Es ist nicht,
die Redaktion TM, sondern es ist so diese Liste von Personen und keine anderen.
Und dann haben sie, und das ist das, das ist das,
sagen wir mal, der Fortschritt gegenüber einer Leaking Plattform, die sich ziemlich genau vor einem Jahr vorgestellt hat,
nämlich Open League, dem Projekt von Daniel Domscheid, was im Prinzip von meiner Betrachtung ja den gleichen Funktionsumfang hatte, nämlich,
äh verschlüsseltes Einwerfen, halb verschlüsseltes halbwegs sicheres Einwerfen einer Datei und dann ein Kommunikations-Beck-Channel auf diesem Server über eben eine geheime URL mit einem geheimen,
Zugang wo dann weiterhin anonym kommuniziert werden kann mit dem,
der Redaktion, ja, es ist ja das genau dieses Problem der Nachfragen, ja? Und das funktioniert also so, dass ich quasi etwas da reinwerfe und dann bekomme ich eine URL zurück, die die ist dann meine geheime URL, mit meinem Zugang und über die,
Auf dieser URL kann ich dann gucken, wenn die Redaktion Fragen hat. Dann stehen sie nämlich dort und dann kann ich darauf antworten.
Also da hat sich ein Backchannel habe. Das äh hat dieses Zeit Online-Ding und der große Unterschied ist einfach nur,
dass dieser äh dass dieses Zeit Online-Teil jetzt als Open-Source-Code äh frei verfügbar ist auf Githup, das heißt, ich kann mir.
Open Saurs oder also was ist die gibt's eine Lizenz, ist das jetzt frei? Also da handelt es sich hierbei um freie Software und was ist die Lizenz?
Ja, ja, auf jeden Fall. Ähm ich schaue gerade, was die Lizenz ist. Ähm.
Hier ist gar keine Lizenz angegeben oder ich finde sie jetzt auf Anhieb nicht, aber sie sagen explizit in dem Video, dass jeder das benutzen kann, darf und verbessern soll,
Also es ist auf jeden Fall ähm offen.
Das heißt im Prinzip könnte es sein, dass sie damit äh so eine Art,
für Zeitungen, um so eine Kommunikation zu ermöglichen. Ist denkbar.
Ist denkbar. Und äh wäre natürlich äh,
natürlich zu hoffen.
Gibt natürlich keine Garantie dafür. Jetzt, ich spiele jetzt mal hier so ein bisschen äh,
äh wie sagt man? Äh Diaboli. Ähm,
Ja, was ist die, was ist sozusagen die Garantie dafür, dass dieser veröffentlichte da auch so in der Form läuft? Hm?
Die Garantie ist erstmal nicht da, die Garantie existiert in dem Fall aus dem Tom und dem Dirk,
Zumindest den Dirk kennen wir beide. Ich weiß nicht, ob du den Tom kennst. Ich kenne ihn nicht.
Tom Lazar. Ja. Kenne ich, ja?
Dirk Engling.
Ja. Beide.
Computerclub. So, das sind erstmal Leute, bei denen man vertrauen kann, wenn die was opensourcen, äh dass das dann auch so auf der Kiste läuft. Es gab, als es veröffentlicht wurde, ähm,
Würde ich mal behaupten, noch kleinere Fehlerchen,
der Form, wie die Zeit, das da online gestellt hat,
Ähm sie hatten aber dann auch sofort auf das,
ähm verwiesen, wo es dann auch einige,
zu bestimmten Dateien gab und so wie es aussieht wurde dann noch ähm.
Dann auch noch einige Dinge an der an diesem Code verändert. Es sind Peißen,
ich das richtig gesehen habe, setzt das irgendwie.
Ja, ich hatte irgendwo gesehen, dass das auch irgendwie an so und so an.
Würde mich äh nicht wundern, wenn das auf basiert war, wenn der Tom Lazar dabei ist, dann ist es äh planen, genau.
Also und so weiter. Und äh ich weiß nicht, ob's am Anfang so war, aber jetzt läuft das bei der Zeit auch wirklich auf einer getrennten Kiste, was schon mal natürlich ganz äh ganz schön ist ähm und das war anfangs, glaube ich, gab's da noch so kleinere,
äh kleinere Kritikpunkte, die man hätte anbringen können, die es implementiert war. Aber ja, es gibt ein,
oder ein, ja, ein Open Stores, anonymen Briefkasten, den Leute geschrieben haben, die größtenteils in der Angelegenheit wissen, was sie tun.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr ähm fortschrittlicher.
Nochmal ein bisschen Eigenwerbung machen mit jedem erwähnten Tom Lazar,
eben zu diesem Thema und der Artgeist, der war ja auch schon ein paar Mal dabei.
Ja, da gehe ich von aus, zu welchen Themen war der dabei alles.
Betont.
Ja, der hat ja mit betont, kennt er sicher aus.
Da kennt er sich auf jeden Fall äh aus, genau. Der hat den open Trecker geschrieben, den ich ja auch äh lange Zeit verwendet habe hier für die,
und der auch so, sagen wir mal, die Software war auf der lief. Ähm.
Tracker, der aus Performance-Gründen hauptsächlich im Rahmen läuft.
Ja, ja, genau, das war also der ist, sagen wir mal, auch Spezialist für äh Hochperformance, ne, also das äh ist so jemand, der wirklich äh auf allen Ebenen zu optimieren, äh weiß, ins Detail äh äh geht und natürlich da auch,
sagen wir mal, die niederen Schichten der Computertechnologie auch sehr vollständig verstanden hat,
Ja, so sehr viel mehr kann man jetzt zu den beiden da nicht sagen. Also das ist auf jeden Fall Kompetenz am Start und das ist interessant, wie auch die Zeit ähm sich in letzter Zeit, also Zeit online konkret äh mit,
Experten auf allen Ebenen äh umgibt und das halte ich auch für einen extrem,
guten Trend, ne? Also auch diese ganzen Visualisierungsprojekte, denen sie auch.
Michael Kreil und.
Genau, zum Beispiel und doch äh einigen anderen Namen, die wir jetzt nicht alle aufzählen äh wollen und können,
Das äh äh verdient meiner Meinung nach äh mindestens Aufmerksamkeit, wenn ich auch Anerkennung.
Also ist auf jeden Fall sehr,
ein sehr schöner Vorschuss und einer, auf den man lange warten musste, ja, also was die,
vor einem Jahr der Open League äh gemacht hatte. Das war ja irgendwie ein Rohrkrepierer mit äh,
dann noch anschließend im großen Ärger innerhalb des Chaos, Computerclubs Berlin und Chaoscomputerclubs bunt und ähm
jetzt das Ganze einfach mal wirklich so, wie es sich gehört, ähm,
Open da zur Verfügung zu stellen. Kann man jetzt eigentlich hoffen, dass dieser Strom an Leuten, der sich natürlich anfangt, sofort auf dieses äh geworfen hat und da äh rumkommentiert hat. Ähm,
dass der nicht abreißt und da vielleicht konstante Verbesserungen stattfinden, ja, also dass also die Idee,
Also was Open Leagues einmal sein sollte, dass diese Idee dann auch mit einem mit einer entsprechenden Würdigung des Open,
vielleicht da tatsächlich eine Realisierung findet, denn wie gesagt Open Leaks gab's nie einen Saurscode für zu sehen,
und entsprechend war natürlich die Prüfung der Angelegenheit, zu der da aufgerufen wurde beim Camp letzten Jahres, äh, eine sehr schwieriges Unterfangen.
Jo
Aber wie gesagt, wir Linken trotzdem nur auf den Artikel von Kai Biermann, der dann nochmal erklärt, was man,
beachten soll und was diese Plattform ist und was sie nicht ist,
Ja, das muss man sich, das ist also sind sehr wichtige Sache, die es zu verstehen gilt, spätestens seit äh dem, was wir bei Wiki Leaks beobachtet haben, was da äh.
Dass es dann eben Whistleblower gibt oder einen gibt, der sich da leider äh dann.
Sei es durch die Hilfe von oder ohne irgendwie selbst verraten hat,
und dass natürlich das die größte Sorge ist und da muss man natürlich leider äh wird es glaube ich auch in,
Zukunft nicht möglich sein, so eine äh Leaking Möglichkeit zu schaffen, die äh für Schimpansen,
Nutzbar ist. Also es ist einfach notwendig, dass man sich mit dem Thema auseinandersetzt, um dem Risiko, was man da eingeht, äh gerecht werden zu können und das selber einschätzen zu können, ja? Und deswegen,
wichtig dann auch diese Erläuterung in dem Artikel von Kai Biermann.
Genau. Ich schätze mal die beiden äh Tom Tuck wenn dann nicht Zuflucht in der Bolivianischen Botschaft suchen müssen.
Hier, ganz witzig, bald ist ja hier, oh ja, Errater letztes Mal, Olympia, es ist überhaupt keine Olympiade.
Jetzt durch mit dem Thema, machen wir noch hier ein kleines.
Letztes Mal, es ist gerade gar nicht Olympiade in London. Olympiade war die letzten vier Jahre, jetzt sind olympische Spiele.
Das war jetzt sehr wichtig, dass dass man das mal herausgearbeitet hat, weil sonst,
wäre ja auch die Welt in ihren Grundfesten erschüttert so, ne,
kam das für Thorsten.
Wir haben noch wahrscheinlich noch ein paar andere aufmerksam,
weil die äh sich um solche Details kümmern. Aber ist ja äh schön, wenn man wieder was dazugelernt, ne.
Aber am Ende der Olympischen Spiele.
Ja, fängt wieder eine Olympiade an.
Fängt wieder in Olympiade an und Ecuador möchte verlautbaren lassen, wie sie, was sie mit ihrem Dauergast. Julian Assanger,
äh Gedenken zu tun und ich sage mal, sie haben die Entscheidung insofern vorausgenommen, als dass sie zu Beginn der Olympischen Spiele gesagt haben, na, wir sagen das dann nach, wir wollen hier nicht die Stimmung versauen,
Haben sie nicht gesagt.
Wollen während der Olympischen Spiele hier nicht die, die Stimmung versauen, wir geben das danach bekannt,
Und äh werden und was auch noch in den letzten drei Wochen war das dann also Schweden nochmal offiziell gesagt hat, wir kommen nicht nach, wir kommen nicht in die,
äh equarianische Botschaft, um euch da zu befragen.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Spannend.
Ist echt spannend, aber also ich ich sage, ich liebe diese Geschichte, ja,
egal, was die machen, das wird auf jeden Fall noch witzig.
Ja, sonst können wir hier unsere Sendung eigentlich auch schon fast einstellen Mangel an Themen,
Ja und dann äh war's das hier wahrscheinlich auch, ne? Euer Netz politisches Gossip Boulevard Magazin, Laubbuchnetzpolitik, immer mit dem heißesten Scheiß von euren Netzpromis.
Came dot com.
Ja. Ja, wir schauen, wir schauen ihn wirklich alle auf den Schritt und äh wissen einfach, was passiert ist.
Schalten sie auch nächste Woche wieder ein, wenn es heißt, Tim oder Kim.
Okay, genug Unfrucht, die Sendung ist auch schon viel zu lang, aber für eine Rückkehrsendung aus dem Urlaub äh nehmen wir uns das jetzt mal heraus. Nächste Woche wird's dann wieder kürzer,
Mit solchen Voraussagen lagen wir ja schon immer richtig.
Ja, selbstverständlich, selbstverständlich. Und jetzt bitte nicht schon wieder achtziger Mucke.
Einfach nur Stille.
Ciao, ciao.
Tschüss.